is the institution left
controls it's own destiny,
and continues to do all
the things it needs to do
to be sustainable.
So, if you have somebody
who's constantly looking back,
to draw the past to the future,
it's not very helpful.
- I respect that.
- So people have to continually reinvent
the future going forward.
- I agree.
- Now, just to show that I am human,
(Gary laughs)
when I left, what I
learned really quickly is
the projects I got involved with,
there was a tremendous curiosity
of transferring my skills,
having worked in the phone
business for 46 years,
and transferring them to other things.
And so, while everything
I've done since I retired
is neither as important or as big as I did
when I worked at Verizon.
Almost everything I do is very important
to the people I work with.
- No question.
- So I serve on the board of a hospital,
I serve on the board of
Genome Center in New York.
I'm working with three or
four startup companies.
I do some consulting with
an investment banking firm.
And all those activities
draw upon my experience.
- No question.
- And there' a lot of fun.
You have a lot of fun doing that stuff.
- So let's go way back.
You're a kid growing up where?
- Well, I'm a Bronxite;
I grew up in the Bronx.
- [Gary] Were you a big Yankee fan?
- Well, it's very interesting.
- Oh, this is gonna be good.
- The question is,
am I a Yankee fan?
So sure--
- A man of your generation
from the Bronx not being
a total diehard Yankee fan
is gonna have a good story.
So I'm excited right now.
- So, I was a Yankee fan.
And I like the Yankees.
- Keep going.
- However, in high
school we played baseball
against Ed Kranepool.
And Kranepool became a Met.
And then the Yankees fired Yogi.
- [Gary] Yes they did.
- And once they fired Yogi, I
was no longer a Yankees fan.
- So you were such a big Yankee fan.
- Well, how could you not be a Yankee fan
when you're eight years old.
- No, I apologize.
I said the wrong thing.
You were such a big Yogi fan,
that the firing of Yogi--
- I hated the way
the Yankees treated Yogi
when they fired him.
- [Gary] I get it.
- And then I needed an excuse
to root for the Mets, anyway.
So, I've been a Met fan ever since.
- [Gary] I love it.
- And I am, today, one of
the small minority owners
of the Mets.
- Oh okay.
- So that's even more fun.
- Yeah, that's even more fun.
You know what's really funny about this,
this is something that,
maybe, people don't know,
I grew up a big Yankee fan,
in Jersey, which you have split.
I was a Jets, Yankee guy.
So, it was like you had
different kind of allegiances.
But the Yankees won in
'96, and that was it.
When the Rangers won in '94 to
when the Yankees won in '96,
I stopped rooting for my favorite team.
Like, literally, just
winning a championship
has been the finishing
point to the journey.
And I'm actually raising
my son a Mets fan.
Because his cousins are Met fans.
And so, we're gonna go
through a very similar thing,
'cause I'm gonna get sucked in
at some point.
- I like both teams.
But I'm a Met fan.
- [Gary] Yeah, I get it.
- And when the Yankees play the Mets,
I root for the Mets.
- [Gary] I understand; you're a Mets fan.
- Absolutely.
- What about football? Giants?
- [Ivan] Jets.
- Jets!
- Yes.
- Very good.
All right, my complete energy has changed.
Okay, so, go ahead, please.
- Actually, if you think about it,
growing up in New York in the '60s,
I wasn't corporate.
- I get it.
- So I liked the Jets, like the Mets.
You get that, right.
- I get it.
What year did you switch to Mets?
Do you know?
- Well, first year, well.
- [Gary] Right away.
The Yankees fired Yogi
in '64 I believe, right?
And the Mets were in '62.
So I started right there in '62.
- And when the Mets made Yogi manager,
you were pumped.
- I loved it.
- You must've loved that (laughing).
- And as a kid I was a Willie Mays fan.
- How old were you in '69,
when the Jets and Mets won?
- I was born in '46.
- [Gary] Oh, so you were perfect.
You were in a beautiful age.
So you really got it.
- Oh yeah, no, my
generation, New York sports.
- Knicks.
Dodgers and Giants were
in New York in the '50s.
So it was great.
New York was full of great sports.
- I love it.
All right, so, you grow up in the Bronx.
What kind of kid are you?
Entrepreneur? Student?
What kind of dude were you?
- [Ivan] Dopey kid.
- Okay, (laughing),
that's the right answer.
I mean listen, that's the answer.
- [Ivan] You know, I
lollygagged through school.
- Did it challenge you?
- I wouldn't say that.
I think that the schools I
went to were good schools,
they challenged you.
But I was a dopey kid.
I didn't pay attention.
And I ended up going to Lehman College.
At the time it was Hunter College.
Went for one year, it's in the book.
They threw me out after a year;
I didn't have good grades.
And I got a job working
for the phone company,
luckily.
- As what?
- As a, well, actually-
- This is my high school report card.
No matter how dopey you are,
you're gonna have to really, really work
at challenging that beauty.
- I would challenge you with my--
- Do you have it?
- I probably have it some place.
- I need to see that evidence.
Go ahead.
- So anyway, I went to college.
I got a job during the day
working a freight elevator in Manhattan.
Then I got drafted.
Because I was 1A.
And lo and behold, I'd
worked for the phone company
for one month, when I got drafted.
And I served in the Service for 24 months.
And the thing about the phone company is,
they used to write me letters
and send me information.
They treated me like I
still belonged to them
even though I only worked
for them for a month.
- Wow, what company?
- It was New York Telephone.
- New York Telephone.
- And then when I came out of the Army,
I went back to work for
the telephone company,
and went back to night school,
and finished night school 12 years later.
Phone company was always
a great place for me
because they took care of me
and they helped me grow up.
So I went from dopey kid to--
- Not as dopey.
- To an Army Veteran.
You learn a lot of stuff in the Army.
And then you work in a big institution,
you learn a little discipline.
And then I met my wife when
I got out of the Service.
And she gave me more discipline.
(Gary laughs)
And then you build a career.
And then, you know, one
thing leads to the other.
- And let's spend a few minutes
on one thing leads to the other.
New York Phone Company until when?
- Sorry?
- You were
in the New York Phone Company until when?
- Oh no, I was, if you look at it
the way you asked the question,
I started in the New York
Telephone Company in 1966
and was part of the system
until I retired in 2011.
- That's what I'm looking for,
the consolidation, the breaking out,
the mergers, the end of day,
how did it all go down?
- Well, I started in New
York Telephone Company.
I went to AT&T.
I worked a little bit at Dell Laboratories
when AT&T was broken up,
back in the early '80s.
I went with the New York Regional Company.
And then they moved me to Washington.
And I lived in Washington.
Then we started
consolidating the companies.
And then we bought cellular companies,
and we started
reconstructing the industry.
You know I was one of the people
that, over the years, had
had a lot of experience
in working at different
parts of the system.
So, probably my contribution
to Verizon, probably,
was to help reconstruct the industry
after the government broke it up.
We spent the next 25 years
recreating a different industry,
but one that had scale and scope,
focused on wireless, focused on broadband.
All the things you guys like.
- Can we focus a little
bit on the breakup?
- [Ivan] Yeah, sure.
- How long was that in the air
before it actually went down?
How long was it in the
public consciousness,
or behind the scenes, or in the press,
with that, hey, this thing is actually
gonna get broken up?
- So, good question.
So it's a good question
because it has relevance
to what's going on today
with the tech companies.
- That's why I'm asking.
By the way, in that crappy report card,
the only good grades I had were History.
Besides Gym; I was a Gym Class hero.
Four A's; they're the only
A's on my report card,
but I asked that question,
and you're very astute, it's self-serving,
I do think history is an
enormous indicator to the future.
And I haven't had the
opportunity to really dig in.
So I'm taking my at-bat right now.
I'm curious.
- So, in a nutshell, if you
looked at the old Bell system,
the old AT&T in the '70s,
there were two complaints
that just wouldn't go away.
The first is they were
stifling new entrants
from coming into the market.
So, they were a big monopoly.
And no matter how many companies
wanted to get into the phone business,
even thought the technology
was there for it to happen,
it never really blossomed.
And the second thing is
the government itself
kinda gave up and said,
they're too big to regulate.
We can't figure it out.
And so, to your question,
that was going on
for probably five to 10 years before that.
But it never got traction.
But then it started
to get traction.
- Why?
From your one man's point of view?
- Well, okay, A, the government
was getting more serious about it.
And they were suing the
company all the time.
They were getting extremely aggressive
about trying to correct those things
that they thought were a problem,
which were barriers to entry
and they couldn't regulate it.
But the other thing that
happened is, the company itself
lost the ability to grow.
So, once AT&t itself said, look,
I can't deal with all this
government interference
and regulation,
and I'm having trouble growing.
- Myself.
That's when they got together
and they agreed on a consent decree
that broke up the company.
So, if you look at today,
some of the tech
companies, not all of them,
but some of them,
they look too big to regulate.
They've become global.
They've had no allegiance,
nor grounding, in any country.
They operate to a
different set of standards.
And people are getting
frustrated that simple things
that should be governable, aren't.
Now, they haven't run into
the problem with new growth.
- That's right.
- But they will.
At some point, growth will slow,
and there will be forces
in which governments around
the world and companies
will come to the conclusion
there's another paradigm
that's necessary.
- I understand.
- So, these things run in cycles.
Now, I tend to be more market-based.
So I'm not looking for
government mandated solutions.
I think tech companies
deserve a lot of credit
for what they've built.
But they have run into a situation,
which not all of them
are serving customers
the way they should.
- I understand.
- And so, therefor, I think
these things will come to a head
over the course of the
next four or five years.
- One of the things
that's interesting to me
in the current state of tech companies
versus the AT&T parallel
is there weren't alternatives
to use a different phone provider.
The alternatives were super difficult.
Your ability to not use Facebook
or Google is quite high.
My ability to use Yahoo or
Bing as a search engine,
or not be on Facebook or Instagram,
is extraordinarily high.
I think one of the most fascinating things
that are happening right now,
in the current conversation
of tech companies,
is the shocking inability for Americans
to take any level of
accountability on themselves.
- Well, so this is interesting.
If you go to, history would say,
people used to make that
argument about Coca Cola.
They're the cause of obesity.
Well, people would make that
case against the phone company
by saying we're teaching
kids to sit on the phone.
- Say that one more time,
because I'm really excited
at what you just said.
I wanna get back to Coke.
- I'm not advocating.
- No, I know you're not.
- But as a businessperson.
- No, no.
I love what you just said.
The amount of parents right now
that are too young to remember an era
when the phone company was blamed
for kids being on the phone all day.
I mean they're just doing the same thing.
I watch parents, yet,
complain about the iPad.
And I'm like, take the
iPad away from your kid.
As if the iPad, as if
Apple, controls them.
- No, but as a business.
- Yeah, I'm listening.
- We have to be sensitive to
these kinds of arguments.
- Of course.
Of course.
- We have to balance making money
against doing the right thing.
- Of course.
- But yet you have to pay
attention to these things
over the course
of your history.
- Of course.
- Because the public will
hold you accountable.
- Of course.
But, where's the public's accountability?
I mean, to me, that is the great,
fascinating thing about this.
You know, maybe I'm hypersensitive to this
because I was born in the Soviet Union.
But, listen, I commend Apple debating
should they make apps that
stop you from screen time.
It's all very wonderful.
Coca Cola has Diet Coke.
There is zero-sugar Coca Cola.
Where does it stop and start?
Mike Bloomberg, in this great city,
tried to limit how big a soda is,
and got the reaction in the other way.
I think what's fascinating
is watching people,
I'm fascinated by 70 or
80 years of prosperity.
Listen, you're a man from
a different generation
than a lot of the people that
I'm referring to right now,
who, you know, I believe that
we've had so much prosperity
in this country,
that we've gotten quite,
I'm just fascinated by
lack of accountability.
I really am.
- Well, so this is a political discussion.
So I'm not gonna
go into it.
- Yeah, and honestly,
you'll appreciate this,
I am not, actually, to your point,
I'm not really interested
in the political.
- But as a business--
- Please.
- As a business discussion.
- To me,
it's a business discussion.
- Yeah, so I agree with
almost everything you said.
But there is an issue
that we have looked at
the last 30 years.
And we have created more inequality
than we intended to create.
So we have overdosed on technology,
we've overdosed on--
- Yeah, but listen.
- Displacing people with technology.
- You're preaching.
- [Ivan] So we have to figure that out.
- I'm with you.
And, to your point,
not to make this a political conversation,
here's the problem:
Our overdosing on technology
hasn't even begun.
There's a naivete,
right?
- Exactly.
- I mean tech,
this is the, right this second,
is the least amount of
technology involvement
in perpetuity.
- Correct.
- So, we need to accept that.
Because ideology is super fun.
But making your kids spend
an hour less on the iPad
is not gonna solve a lot
of these human truths.
- So, if we look at,
I'll use our business.
- And I apologize, real
quick, to cutting you off.
I think, to segue a little bit,
'cause I think it's gonna
bring value to the audience,
what I love about the
conversation we're having,
is these are the macro-trends that CEO,
where she and he has to be thinking about
on an everyday basis of the micro,
these things we're talking
about in the world,
is how you thought about the four walls,
the virtual four walls
of Verizon for 16 years.
Everything is important at all times.
The amount of things that happen here.
The point you were making about Coca Cola.
- [Ivan] Yeah, I wasn't picking on them.
- No you weren't, you were
actually doing exactly right.
I spend every day about
perception becomes reality
becomes what you have to deal with.
- So if I can bring this,
fast-forward?
- Please.
- So one of the things our industry
always had a lot of pride in.
When we moved from first
generation wireless to third,
now to fifth generation wireless, 5G,
what we hope will happen
is that industries
that have been untouched by technology,
will be disrupted and transformed.
- Well, especially 5G.
I do not believe--
- So, let's take an example.
- People do not understand
the technology jump
that this is about to be.
- So let me use
my favorite example.
- Please.
- Banking has been changed, right?
Retail has been changed.
If you go into a classroom,
it looks the same
as it did 40 years ago.
And so, when I look at education,
where is the technological disruption
that should have occurred in that
over the last 30, 40 years?
So we didn't see that happen.
Healthcare's another place.
The environment's a third.
So, to me the business
community has lots to give.
But there's an uneven focus
around where technology gets deployed.
Some of that is inertia.
Some of that is government.
Some of that is entrenched interests.
But the fact is we need to take
the technological revolution
and apply it aggressively across industry.
So we need,
you know Amazon did what it did.
We need an Amazon of education.
We need and Amazon of environment
to really apply the technology.
And that would create jobs,
and it would create value,
and it would start to slant
what we're now looking at
is all this inequality of
jobs and educational skills.
- I understand.
Let's take this in a different turn.
What about, in your career,
who were your biggest mentors
and what were some of
the best pieces of advice
you got from them?
- Early in my career, I
was probably uncoachable.
- [Gary] 'Cause you thought you
were right about everything?
- No, because, you know I'm a city kid.
You figure you can figure
everything out yourself.
But what I think, the way I would
answer the question.
- You can fully tell,
I believe it.
- Yeah, no, I can see that.
I can see that.
What I did though, is I
used to copy the people
who did things I liked.
And so, somebody, I used to
like the way they dressed.
Well somebody else, in a meeting,
would handle bad news very well.
Or somebody would have
a positive attitude.
And so I used to use,
my mentors were those
people who had attributes
that I thought were pretty cool.
- You know, I actually
analyzed that as a street kid.
You're using your environment
to make adjustments.
- That's true.
And I learned, as I
moved up in the company,
people watched everything I did.
- [Gary] 100%
- So, to me, imitation is
the best form of teaching
that you can give people
if you do the right thing
or if you try to do the right thing.
- And it's an incredible
sense of responsibility
once you make that realization.
- So, to answer your question,
my mentors were the people
who handled controversy well,
who had a good attitude,
who were always prepared.
- How much do you think
positivity matters?
I mean that.
Practical positivity.
When I say something like that,
how does that register in your mind?
- So, remember now, I'm an East Coast kid.
So when I hear that term,
I wanna make sure I ferret out the fluff.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- So, I like people with
a positive attitude.
But I like people who are
practical, street smart,
and get things done.
Not people who like to
yak it to 20,000 feet,
just get--
- You mean,
pontificating positivity?
- [Ivan] That's a word.
- That's like, you notice
how I framed it up, right?
I think positivity is imperative,
but if it lacks practicality,
it's an ideology.
- Right, so--
- And it's vulnerable.
- So there was one person
who once gave me some advice,
that's close to this point, Gary,
and that is, we were in a meeting,
and a very contentious subject.
And as typical in a
meeting on the East Coast.
When people get upset with each other,
they attack each other personally.
And so, my boss, who was from Michigan,
on the way back to our office,
he took me aside and he said, Ivan,
why do people around
here attack each other
and not the problem?
And he was sending me a message:
Don't do that.
I never forgot.
Because here I am, 40 years later,
and I've never forgotten.
And I sit in a room and
I can tell the people
who get frustrated with
the facts, or the issue,
or can't articulate their point of view.
And the first thing they
do is attack somebody
instead of attacking the problem.
- [Gary] I like that, Ivan.
- And it's just something,
so that's an example.
- I'm a buyer of that.
- So that's positivity.
- I'm an East Coast Kid.
But I always say that I'm unemotional.
And what I'm really saying
is what you just said.
Which is, the biggest thing
I preach to my direct reports
is if you're not capable
of being the bigger person
in every situation,
then you're vulnerable with me because,
to your Michigan boss' point,
it's just there's no
value in that behavior.
And once in a while,
you know, I love when you
have such a good rapport
when you can do it
and it's almost like you're competing
on the basketball court.
But to your point, it's so, that's cool.
I love that.
That's a great story.
- If I can bring us back
to the book.
- You can do
anything you want, of course.
- If I could bring us back to the book.
There are lots of chapters in there,
but there's a couple favorite chapters
that happened.
- Please.
- One of them is the
story of how our company
was able to deliver after 9/11.
- Let's talk about it.
- So, very quickly.
9/11 occurred.
- Right here.
- We were one of the first
people that were called
by the Department of Homeland Security
because, they said, you guys
must know what's going on.
What's going on?
And we said, we don't
know what's going on.
We saw the second plane hit the tower.
Within 10 minutes.
- When you say you saw?
- We were sitting in our office
at the 42nd Street building,
looking down.
We saw the first tower on flames.
And we saw the plane
hit the second building.
- You physically saw,
from your office window?
- About 30 of us.
- I'm listening.
- Our chief engineer said, right there.
- [Gary] (fingers snap) On that second.
- He said, they don't put that fire out,
that building's gonna collapse.
- And you guys were like,
what the hell are you talking about?
- And we told other people that.
We didn't know if that was right.
But he was right.
And we said to him,
Larry, why is that right?
And he said, because all
the steel's gonna melt.
The center of the building
is gonna collapse.
So, our job then, 'cause
all of Wall Street was out.
All of Manhattan was out.
And what happened after
that was, the next morning,
still flames, still trying
to look for survivors.
The calls were coming in
from all over the country
about when is the Stock Exchange
gonna be up and running?
And every single one of the
trading partners at Wall Street
said, yeah, we'll be up Thursday.
But we knew that wasn't true.
- [Gary] Why did you
know that to not be true?
- Because they couldn't get
their people into the buildings.
Right?
They didn't have alternative locations.
So, I remember Dick Grasso,
who was the Chairman of the
Stock Exchange at the time,
he called a meeting of
everybody in the city.
And he brought our people in.
And he said, what are we gonna do?
And our guys just sat there
and said, there's no way
that you're gonna be able to,
(phone ringing) sorry.
- [Gary] No problem.
- Get the Stock Exchange up and running
because people won't have facilities,
in empty sites.
They weren't even letting people
into Ground Zero at the time.
And anybody who wanted to set
up facilities in New Jersey,
or someplace else, needed time to do it.
So, what was interesting is
our people basically said,
we could do the following,
but here's all the things
you will have to do.
And it was very interesting
how Grasso just gravitated
to our chief guy, Larry Babbio,
and said, so what do you need to do?
And so we talked about what
everybody needed to do.
And the story here was great
because we were running
cables outta buildings.
We were doing all sorts of
things that we needed to do
but we were also helping
other people do their jobs.
So this is the lesson on
9/11 for us: accountability.
There is no such thing as accountability
if you do your job and
the next guy can't do his.
Accountability means we all win together.
And so we ended up committing
to getting the Stock Exchange
up and running the following Monday.
And in the process of doing
that, we developed relationships
with the top 60 or 70 trading partners,
the Goldman Sachs, the Merrill Lynches,
all those companies,
to help them make sure they
could open their facilities,
they had enough circuits
to get things done,
they had the generators and the power,
and everything else that needed to occur
to get the country up and running.
And it was one of the greatest
experiences of our careers,
'cause it was a big deal.
- For sure.
- Was such a big deal.
But it taught out company, back in 2001,
what real accountability is.
Real accountability is
not just doing your job,
but doing your job and helping
the people you work with
do their jobs.
- [Gary] I understand.
Ivan, for, I have such a large audience
of 20, 30, 40 year old entrepreneurs,
or number twos and threes
in smaller companies
quite a bit because the
nature of my business,
senior executives in Fortune 500s.
What are some of the,
just back to the context
of this conversation,
what are some of the things,
back to those 20 or 30 people
that you spent time with,
startups, boards, I'm
sure family and friends,
what are some of the
tried-est and truest things
that come to mind that bring value.
What is some of the advice, or thoughts,
that you've seen bring
actual value to others
in their careers or ambitions
that you feel are like,
I don't wanna call them
your Bill of Rights
or your commandments,
but yes, that kind of stuff.
What are some of the truest
things that you believe in
as an operator, as an executive?
- Probably the thing that
comes to mind first, Gary,
is curiosity and the
willingness to ask questions.
- Having the humility to know
that you don't know everything.
- To help people think through things.
- Yeah, I mean, do you think it's hard,
when you get to such a senior
level as you've sat on,
to show that?
Was it hard for you to develop the ability
to manifest curiosity into
what is humility of a leader?
Or was that something
that came natural to you?
- No, I think in my case,
I always came with the attitude
that I came from the Bronx.
So I don't think it ever dawned
on me that I had the right
to act like I graduated MIT.
- [Gary] I understand.
- I just didn't do that.
So I always worried
about making a mistake.
- [Gary] That's right.
- So, in my case, I think
asking a lot of questions,
being prepared, taking the next step.
- You brought up being
prepared a couple times.
It's not something I think a lot about.
I think I stay in my lane,
so thus, by macro, I'm prepared.
You've brought it up three times now.
Talk to me about that for five seconds.
Are you a--
- I don't think I've ever seen
a presentation brought to me
that there weren't three good questions
that you couldn't ask.
Not to catch people,
but just to dig deeper,
understand the secondary and
the tertiary effects of things.
So, I think it's really
important to be prepared.
I'll just give you one
anecdote that's in the book.
- [Gary] Please.
- It probably helped me make my career
even though it was a freak thing.
- [Gary] I'm excited already.
Seriously, I love this stuff.
- It was in 1981,
and somehow I was on some
sort of a task force.
And I was supposed to make a presentation
to all of the high-level people at AT&T,
including Charlie Brown.
Charlie Brown was the Chairman
and CEO of the company.
And I was sort of a mid-level person.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- And Charlie Brown was a legendary guy.
- [Gary] Yeah, big time.
- So he shows up--
- Had you interacted
with Charlie, at this point?
- Never.
Never met him before.
- So are you scared crapless?
Or you felt prepared?
- I was prepared.
- Okay, keep going.
- And I'll tell you why I was prepared.
- [Gary] I can't wait, I know
there's a punchline coming.
- It had to be 50 people in the room,
all these vice presidents.
And the meeting was eight
o'clock in the morning.
I got there at 6:30 a.m. to
make sure everything worked.
And he comes--
- What was the technology
of the day, in '81, working?
- It was overhead graphs.
You had to make them.
And so he walks in at
one minute to 8:00 a.m.
and he sits down, no chit
chat, he says, proceed.
Dead silence.
And everybody's sitting
there with their arms folded.
Nobody's smiling anymore.
- [Gary] Not the warmest room of all time?
- No, it was okay.
So, I started the presentation,
and he goes, I know that.
Okay, put up the second chart.
He goes, I know that.
Third chart, he goes I know that.
And I said no you don't.
- Really?
- Yeah, and I didn't mean it
to be disrespectful.
- It just came natural.
- Right, I just said, I
know you don't know this.
And he, dead silence in the room,
he looks at me and he goes, okay, proceed.
So, he showed me something.
He didn't get upset.
He just tested it, and
then we talked it through.
Now the gist of the whole presentation
was, even though AT&T
signed this consent decree
with the government,
and they were gonna break up the system.
My point to them was the
government wasn't gonna cooperate
with making this happen easily.
So we were gonna have to
do some things on our own.
And I remember his lawyers
and all his vice presidents
would go nuts.
And he just sat there.
He just sat there.
And at the end of the
presentation he goes,
thank you very much.
He got up and left.
That's what he did.
And, of course, everybody
came up to me and said,
you're screwed; you
might as well quit now.
And I remember nothing
happened for about a week.
Then I got a call from my vice president,
who was a very big, big person.
He says, come into the office.
And he brought in all the naysayers.
And he said, now before
everybody starts screaming,
he goes, and I had a beard
at the time, full beard.
(Gary laughing)
Full beard; nobody had a beard at AT&T.
Walter Kelly was his name,
and he said to everybody in the room,
he said, we have four sons,
and they all have facial hair.
This was in 1980, right.
And he goes, we can't get them to shave.
He goes, what is it with you young people?
- You were 45 though,
right?
- No, I was almost,
um 1980?
- 'Cause you were born in '46, you said?
- '66.
- Oh, '66, right.
- '66, no, no, 46.
- Oh so you're,
no, no, 46.
- I was born in '46.
- So you're 44, 45 actually.
- Well no--
- Right, this is '81,
you said.
- '81, yeah, right, right.
Let's do the math, right?
'86 I was 40, right?
- Oh, I'm sorry, you're right.
My math was off, go ahead.
Keep going.
- Do I have the math right?
- Yeah, you got the math right.
I got it wrong.
Go ahead.
- I wouldn't want my shareholders
to think I couldn't--
- No, no, my math is off.
I apologize.
Go ahead.
- So, anyway, he said,
he said, what is it with you young people?
And we just laughed.
And then he said to everybody in the room,
listen to the young man.
That's just what he said.
Now this was a high-level person at AT&T.
You would never think he would have
that kind of flexibility
and humility, but he did.
So it's a lesson--
- Winning player.
- A lesson I never forgot.
- I believe in it the most.
- Never forgot.
- Nothing makes me happier
than being wrong.
I always think I'm right.
- But, Gary, if I wasn't prepared
and didn't have the self-confidence.
- [Gary] You would have never said it.
- I would have never said it.
- [Gary] I totally get it, brother.
- I would have just moved
through the conversation.
- My man, my man,
honestly, as somebody who always thinks
there's a second game in the room,
this is basically how I live my life.
The amount I know about
executives that work for me,
clients, co-founders,
fancy people in the world
that people think are brilliant,
the amount of things I know
by asking a singular question
at a meeting.
The amount of times I've made up something
to see if that person just
agrees to appease the sit.
It's the most important,
you have to get it.
When you are sitting in a world
where you walk in one
minute before a meeting
and you've gotta navigate that much,
and time is your biggest enemy.
You have to create all
these secondary skill sets
to be able to understand
the situation at hand.
I've an incredible read on humans,
based on moments like that.
- Coming back to Verizon Untethered,
we believed, as a culture,
we were as curious
as any culture could ever be.
So, the head of my wireless company,
or the head of some of the units,
when they knew I was
traveling around the country
for whatever reason,
they would give me a list
of stores to go into,
and say go make a field visit.
And I used to do that.
And we all used to do that.
And we would just go--
- Did the stores
know you were coming?
- [Ivan] No.
- Because one of the
things I hated growing up
in the liquor business is,
my dad had a big liquor store,
and when the Smirnoffs, or the Absolut,
or the Budweiser big dogs would come,
we would stage the store.
And I remember when I finally was 16
and had some level of a voice,
which I really didn't, even at 16,
but I'd been working in the
store for a couple years
at that point.
I said, Dad, we're not
doing that person a service.
And he looked at me like I was crazy.
I remember when I took
over operations at 22,
I never staged the store.
And the distributor would be pissed.
The regional managers,
the holding companies
would be pissed.
And the CEO, eight out of
10 times, was thrilled.
It was the only truth they got.
I know nobody's drinking
your Vodka, it sucks.
- There's an anecdote in here
that my successor, Lowell McAdam,
used to also make field visits.
He'd go into a store.
If there was a light bulb out,
he would unscrew the light bulb out
and he would mail it to
the district manager.
- [Gary] I get it.
- And you do that across the company
consistently for three, four, five years,
people pay attention
to details.
- 100,000%
- And it's a big thing.
So, curiosity's one thing.
The other thing is--
- Let's get a phone call in here.
- Yeah, the other thing is operational
excellence.
- Go ahead.
- We were sticklers for that.
Now you're always trying to figure out
if you're doing the right
thing for your customers,
but we really worked hard at that.
- You guys built a crazy company.
- [Ivan] We did.
- You really did.
- [Ivan] A lot of people did it.
- Who were your core
competitors when you guys,
in your prime of your career,
when you kind of took on.
What was the comp--
- Well, AT&T, and Sprint,
and T-Mobile were there.
And later on,
on the broadband side.
- Who's disappeared?
- [Phone AI] Enjoy this
Verizon Ringback tone
while your party
is being reached.
- Who was a competitor
when you firs started that
is no longer out there.
Anybody stand out?
- Hello?
- Oh, we got somebody, I apologize.
Who's this?
Robert, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
You're on with Ivan.
Please say hello.
- [Robert] Hey Gary V.
Awesome, you guys are amazing.
Love your show.
- Thank you.
What's your question?
- [Robert] Basically I
actually am a current member
of Verizon Wireless,
and the whole thing with 5G
and our stock in telecommunications,
what's our future gonna look like?
Or, even for small businesses,
is that gonna make everything grow
with small business and
5G it's gonna bring?
In your opinion.
- Ivan, as somebody who's
just kind of headline reading
at this point, and started digging in,
but I've dug in 'cause
there are some clear things
that I'm interested in with 5G.
Maybe, based on that question,
for everybody who's listening,
and I don't know how much
or how little you've gone deep into 5G.
But, if you have gone a little bit deeper,
which I'm gonna make assumptions,
but not necessarily based on
where you are at this point.
What are some of the real bullet points
that you think people are either missing
or the most exciting things to you
about this technology?
- So let me make sure I qualify by saying
that I no longer speak for the company.
- [Gary] I know that.
(Robert laughs)
- But I love the company.
- [Gary] Understood.
- And thank you for your
call and Verizon Wireless.
You guys are doing great, so keep it up.
- [Robert] Oh, thank you very much.
- So 5G, what's different about 5G?
There's a couple of things.
So first of all, the
number of the devices.
- [Gary] Rob, thanks for calling brother.
- The number of devices you
can connect in one square mile
is an order of magnitude
higher than it is today.
So you could create services
in which you have millions of devices
in a very small geographic area.
They use less power.
So you can do the same
thing with far less power.
The latency, the speed of
switching calls, much lower.
- [Gary] That seems to be
a really exciting part.
- That's a huge issue.
- The latency thing seems to be
a big play.
- And then the amount of data
that you can transmit is an
order of magnitude tenfold.
The other thing is, the
cost to transmit the data
is much lower.
So when you look at--
- I think the name itself,
confuses the end consumer,
'cause it's one tick up,
yet the magnitude is so extraordinary.
- Yeah, and that's the same thing happened
when we went from three to 4G.
- That's right.
But, three to 4G, and
correct me if I'm wrong,
it seems, especially on latency,
which I think effects a lot of things,
it seems like the jump here
is kind of a signature jump.
I just think a lot of people
assume stuff's gonna be faster.
And there's just so much more to it.
- So let's use examples.
I mean, you've heard
these examples before.
We'll take the easy
one: self-driving cars.
- This is a big one for me.
- You know whether you
believe you like it or not,
the fact is, over time, when
you can reduce the latency
and increase the topography and the maps,
you eliminate a lot of problems.
And you could actually run cities.
So, Verizon today is
introducing smart-cities
in Sacramento and Portland.
And traffic lights that can do things.
That's one thing.
So, something more exotic.
Think of healthcare.
With broadband, you could do an operation
with a patient sitting
in Auburn University
and the doctor could be in San Francisco.
- Because of the lack of latency, right?
- Because of the speed of the connection.
- It's in real time,
in essence.
- And the clarity,
in real time.
And just think of what you
could do for, for example,
health services to rural America.
Or health services into poor areas,
and the people who can't travel.
That kind of thing.
Just think what kind of services
you can offer to the
elderly, the latchkey.
That's not our thing,
in the phone company.
I mean we do the infrastructure.
- [Gary] That's right, you're the pipes.
- We put the network in.
And I always get uncomfortable
that we have to explain
what the applications are,
when you've got--
- Right, 'cause the market
needs to take over.
- Yeah, the market
will catch up to it and it'll do it.
The market'll create it.
- But the infrastructure
network and pipes, in essence,
allow for so many more innovations.
- Well, just think,
what you're reading now,
which, again, you could like it or not,
but all of a sudden the gambling industry
has figured this out.
And just think of what
they're gonna do with--
- You could literally bet on this pitch,
because the speed in
which it's happening now
is not vulnerable to the connection.
- [Ivan] And you could
be sitting in Miami,
betting on a game in Chicago.
- That's right.
Or literally this pitch.
Because I mean, it really does matter.
- Yes, now, that may not
be the perfect use of 5G.
But there may be other things that--
- Look, somebody getting escapism
because they love betting
on every pitch of baseball,
back to, you said
something very important,
which is the big things
you were doing at Verizon.
Well for the three-person
startup in Cincinnati
that you're helping,
they're problems are the
biggest problems, to them,
in the world.
To the person who literally
got shot and is in a hospital,
and can be helped by somebody
who understands this situation
better than anybody there,
and can electronically do
it from somewhere away,
guess what?
Staying alive is the
biggest thing in the world.
But the person sitting
in their living room
who's not happy with their
life and needs escapism,
and needs to gamble on a baseball game
to be able to get through their day,
that's their most important
thing at their life.
And I think that's just humans.
- I'll use my famous whipping toy, here.
So you think about it,
I grew up in era where you
had to go to a sports event,
go to the stadium, you
participate in sports.
Now, it's virtual.
You can watch any soccer game,
any game, any time you want.
So, the one industry
that's never changed
its model, is education.
It just drives me crazy.
It absolutely drives me crazy
that we could be teaching
people so much quicker
if we applied all this technology
in a way that allows--
- What about the fact
that we continue to teach people
to memorize information
when information is at your fingertips.
Let's just, how 'bout the curriculum
that fills the format?
You know it's absurd what
we're doing with that.
- Well your audience understands this, so.
- But it takes--
- But there's hope.
There's really a lot of hope.
- Its also on us, this goes
back to accountability,
if parents continue to think
a diploma from a college is the KPI,
and is going to set their kids
up for happiness and success,
we will continue to be vulnerable.
I think, you know it's funny,
I think that television commercials
are grossly overpriced media.
And I've been advocating that
as an adman of the new version
for the last decade.
I just thought that the
biggest brands in the world
would become more educated over time
and know how to spend
their money more wisely.
I did not anticipate OTT networks,
like Hulu, and Amazon Prime, and Netflix,
to completely eliminate, over time,
people even consuming the
content of the big three networks
let alone the commercials.
I feel like that's what's
going to happen with education.
This is not gonna be the education system
figuring itself out,
because there's too many
inherent interests, needs,
and putting history on a pedestal.
This is something coming from the outside,
disrupting at another level,
that it has no choice.
- Yeah, well there isn't enough
competition in education.
- The end. The end.
- That's part of the problem.
- The cab industry wasn't
gonna make it better for us
so that we could get a phone
to pick me up in two seconds
'cause time is valuable to me.
It took an outside force,
and then everybody kicks in.
- You know, for many years,
one of the challenges we had
was kids coming out of
either high school or college
didn't have the minimum requirements
to do the jobs that we had.
- I get it.
- So we would have to spend--
- [Gary] From an engineering standpoint?
- Not those jobs, but you know,
customer facing jobs.
- I see.
- Technicians jobs.
- We spent a lot of money
training people to do things
that they should've learned in school.
- I get it.
Listen, we could have 17 episodes
of our points of view on school, clearly.
- No, I'm positive about it
because I think this will,
there is a will in this country.
And as long as we don't
destroy the culture
of people wanting to succeed
and live the American Dream, and work.
This summersault
kind of thing.
- We're now back
to not getting political.
We won't destroy.
That's the DNA of this place.
This ebbs and flows, but
the DNA of this place.
Now, look, every empire
falls for a reason.
Too much success.
- Well, there's a lot of
competition in the world.
So I think, if anything,
we'll have to respond to that.
- Yeah, the kid growing up
in China as an only child
in a lower class family,
is way more hungry than you.
And that's gonna play out.
- It will.
- It sure will.
I appreciate you being on the show.
- Thank you for having us, thank you.